la demande à manu payet car il est ce
soir notre invité bonsoir et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci
le seul bon soir avant de venir sur le
film une petite question les bons la
manche ou de carré comme l'avait demandé
à la sortie de l'avion si oui moi manger
ouais mais la mange trop ah bon c'était
quoi bell a plusieurs c'est un problème
mais là ça marche pas ça va mais un
carré appel lot
il brave we will eux mêmes c'est que là
on est là pour le travail qu'on peut pas
à la réunion pour le travail la réunion
terre de tournage
ah ouais c'est une grosse production
française comme la réunion at-elle été
choisie comme lieu de tournage bat déjà
c'était mon espoir vraiment en fait
quand j'ai rencontré la réalisatrice
mélissa m'a confié que c'était compliqué
d'envisager hawaï parce que c'est
l'amérique et parce que
les tournages aux etats unis c'est
compliqué les règles sont différentes et
c'est assez loin et puis il y avait
aussi la crise sanitaire et donc moi aux
autres tout cela fait dire des gros mots
que je fais et donc est donc en fait moi
j'ai espéré à ce moment là quand elle me
confiait ça j'espérais qu'elle quelle
qu'elles choisissent la réunion en fait
mais au moins je savais que c'était la
meilleure idée ça reste la france c'est
un peu loin aussi mais voilà c'était
moins compliqué de toute façon et puis
tout aussi beau voilà bien le sien un
casting exceptionnel assure se finit
bien casting elodie bouchez yanis bejo
il a enfin manu payet il ya une émotion
particulière de tourner pour la première
fois dans son nid oui oui il ya une
grande émotion et a une très grande
émotion et je je j'appréhendais beaucoup
de revenir moi qui ai toujours parlé à
mes parents à mon père que je n'ai plus
aujourd'hui de cinéma je les saouler
avec ça j'allais toujours j'allais tout
en cinéma je sortais du plaza j'allais
au plaza de jeu après jeu passée dans
l'es3 rythme je passais ma vie au cinéma
et puis quand c'était pas ça c'était des
cassettes vidéo à la maison je jeu de
revenir ici
tourner un film de cinéma pour oui pour
moi c'est vraiment même si ça s'appelle
pas réunion s'appelle ah ouais je dis
que c'est déjà pas mal quand on va voir
la réunion il y aura des réunions mais
non bien sûr
ah oui pis c'était ça comptait aussi
beaucoup pour moi que les équipes
métropolitaines rencontre les équipes
réunionnaises et que et que les
métropolitains les productions pour les
films à venir réalise à quel point il ya
un savoir-faire ya une vraie terre de
tournage il ya une vraie terre qui offre
multiple regarder derrière de la voilà
des paysages tellement divers tellement
tellement différent que qu'il faut s'en
servir et faire travailler puis ça
permet aussi aux jeunes créole filles et
garçons de rêver plus concrètement ça
ils n'ont pas forcément besoin de partir
pour pouvoir a raison de faire des films
dans un premier temps manu payet le
marmaille la révolte est normal que nous
l'a vu toutes les images est aussi le
maître de cérémonie des césars c'était
en 2018 on y revient rapidement une
grosse responsabilité
ah oui va surtout j'ai une grande fierté
il n'y a pas été très fier j'étais très
fier et puis ben pareil j'étais fier
d'être le premier créole a présenté les
césar et puis hein
enfin j'étais très fier j'étais j'ai
représenté la réunion gt gt animé par ça
et puis par le même s'il y avait un
décalage horaire qui faisait que même ma
mère s'est endormi devant j'étais quand
même médicale en deuil pour la prof
d'espagnol c'est ça même si chacun sur
bien sûr il ya eu des clins d'oeil au
début à lesquin dans le milieu il ya eu
des jeux même je m'appelle même rougail
saucisses de dents dans un des sketches
des césar est un clin d'oeil à la fin
qui était dédiée à toutes les
réunionnaises tous les réunionnais qui
avant qui pouvait un jour avoir envie de
faire ça de se dire que ce n'était pas
impossible malgré l'éloignement malgré
cela les onze heures d'avion ben que
c'était faisable
justement vous parlez de rougail
saucisses et un petit mot alors là où la
nuit ici mais quand ça va que ça ramène
dans deux valises tout tout c'est
surtout quand me ça va
qu'est ce qui reste à la région parce
que je prends tout j'essaie de ramener
un maximum de trucs mais je sélectionne
je ramène au curcuma qu'un type de
musique aussi bien sûr comme ça oui si
méchant trouver la musique de mon frère
aussi cas le groupe qui arrive ça non
j'essaie de rapporter tout après
maintenant aujourd'hui grâce au fait
qu'il ya des avions tous les jours et
caetera et pillages voilà si on a des
bonnes connexions on peut réussir à
mettre la main sur des trucs qu'on
trouvait pas avant en étant à paris mais
il faut être patient
et puis il faut pas être trop attaché au
goût le gouvernement sinon il faut juste
se souvenir
merci beaucoup manu payet sur le plateau
ce soir bon ton d'aller cuir revient
quand vous c'est gentil merci beaucoup
si salariaux et puis